yes sir
so what's up what's up with your life
man what have you been doing ever since
we did the podcast every time
it's been it's been what it's been like
six months since
i think would we do it in december
november december something like that
is that what it was yeah maybe even i
don't know no it was way before that
i think it was i think yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um dude that whole thing get a little
bit closer to the mic that whole thing
is um
it's launched my life into a whole
[ __ ] different direction man like
like when i came here and did this first
podcast i didn't have a youtube channel
you know what i mean i had 200 followers
on [ __ ] instagram i didn't have a
youtube channel
i was you know what i mean i was just
tattooing you know like i wasn't really
doing [ __ ] like i wasn't promoting
myself i wasn't promoting the book
really the book was just kind of doing
its thing and
i did this podcast and
it was like overnight overnight
craziness
you know what i mean like i've done
probably 15 or 20 podcasts
since this one because people see the
numbers that this one does and they want
me to come on theirs because they think
it's gonna you know what i mean so they
all want to ride that wave
um you know so you know i did this and
then i've done
everybody's people are flying me out to
dallas you know what i mean i'm doing
mscs and
up in you know down in uh west palm
beach i do that like once a month now
um i launched my own youtube channel
i've got about 50 or so
videos already up on my youtube channel
i went and got a
i went and built a youtube studio in
downtown phoenix
like i went and rented like a legitimate
office and i got the professional
lighting the mics the [ __ ] you know
what i mean the good cameras i'm running
uh
uh sony alpha 6400s i got you know a
couple of those
and uh yeah so i'm me i'm rocking and
rolling man you know like this whole
thing is just absolutely
fire it's it's insane dude now i'm
addicted that's great i'm addicted
it's amazing what it's done for matt cox
too he really took that opportunity and
ran with it ran with every time i talked
to matt cox on the phone he's traveling
to some different state some different
country
he just did a commercial for some
[ __ ] home security company
yeah yeah he's crushing he's everywhere
yeah matt cox is a big d what did you
guys just trying i'm trying to do what
he's doing and i'm kind of i mean he he
he got the big ones he got like the vlad
and he got [ __ ] valuetainment you
know what i mean he was on like the real
big ones
yeah you know now i'm knocking out all
the little guys before i can get up to
the big guys yeah you'll get there yeah
yeah yeah
so yeah no i did i just did the marty
ray project what's that
uh he's it's a podcast he's a dude a guy
out of nashville he's got like uh
600 000 subscribers or something like
that on his channel he's
a musician uh and he does a podcast um
you know i did just recently did that
i just recently did back lovers uh
podcast
um i did tap n i flew out to dallas and
did tap n
i did one of the ones that i do i so
many
like i get and then like all the
opportunities now that are coming up
like i do i wake up to 100 dms on
[ __ ] instagram
every single day every day it's just
insane
you know and then you got all the idiots
that you know because they've seen the
podcast they know teach me how to do the
[ __ ]
you know i mean teach me how to you know
i made a whole video on that that's just
[ __ ]
absolutely bananas have you taught
anybody how to do credit card no well
listen i'm charging i was charging a
thousand dollars a consultation
you know what i mean like you want to
talk to me you want access to me yeah if
you feel like i have some information
that's going to make you millions of
dollars and you're gonna pay for it
so i was charging a thousand dollars a
consultation now i'm charging five
oh yeah five thousand five thousand if
you want if you wanna talk to me if you
want if you want my time
wow now my time it went up because now
honestly
i barely get any sleep dude i i i'm
still tattooing at the shop
eight ten hours a day and then i go
straight from the shop to the studio and
i record youtube till one or two o'clock
in the morning
you know what i mean and i do that every
day and then i fly and then i'm flying
i'm doing podcasts in different cities
and then you know i got all these other
[ __ ] i'm working on and you know i got
the bigger projects
and just like i barely even sleep so now
my time is valuable hell yeah i mean
before i had time to blow i had time to
burn you know what i mean now i'm
[ __ ] you gotta [ __ ] pay me my
money
how much how many 1 000 consultations
have you done
quite a few really yeah quite a few wow
yeah that's [ __ ] insane yeah
quite a few
listen i got guys flying out how do they
get guys wanting to fly out
from other cities to come sit down and
have lunch with me
how do these people get a hold of you if
they want to get a consultation they all
dm me on instagram
you know and then we just go from there
wow what a [ __ ] business
yeah it's pretty wild that's pretty
amazing don't you worry though about
like if somebody did do some crazy [ __ ]
and you taught him how to do it that you
could get in trouble
are you still liking are you are you
still on probation no i'm oh you're off
i'm nothing oh so you're not locked down
like matt nope they killed my paper man
they
yeah when i went back on violation they
gave me nine months and then they just
cut me loose and was like dude you're
not supervisable
apparently that's what the judge told me
you're not supervisable
but but i'm not aware of a bad way [ __ ]
it's insane yeah yeah where she goes
that's the [ __ ] way she goes that's
the way she got what is that from
trailer park boys
you watch trailer park boys yeah man
every [ __ ] episode every season
every movie everything everything they
put out i'm on it
i've been trying to tell danny forever
he's never watched one episode i was
just trying to tell her about it earlier
wasn't i the trailer park boys i was
like you've never seen the trailer
probably i i did some quote from the
trailer park boys yeah and she's like no
that's one nice [ __ ] kitty right
there that's all i know oh bubbles oh
yeah
what a classic so are you gonna what are
you gonna do for the rest of time you're
down here
um see matt dude yeah i'm gonna hang out
with matt and uh do some painting
he's gonna he's gonna give me some tips
on the finer points of
canvas painting and i'm actually gonna
start doing canvas paintings um on my
own and then
selling them uh well trying to hawk them
to my subscribers
which which honestly i put out a video
even like like i was like suggesting
that i was gonna start doing this and
people were
like yeah [ __ ] i'll buy them i'm like
all right this is going to eat it all up
let's [ __ ] do it and it is you know
what i mean it's it's
got to start making merch shirts and
[ __ ] i'm already on it man i've already
got like i sat down i'm a graphic
designer so i did i did like 15 or 20
designs
already and i'm gonna try and [ __ ]
pick like the two or three best of those
and get everything people make the money
get everything printed up yeah i'm gonna
do a whole merch so i'm doing everything
man i'm like i've only i've had my
youtube channel for three months dude
i'm
almost a thousand subscribers that's
amazing man it's growing fast man
it's growing fast what kind of stuff you
talk about on your videos
uh you know just life [ __ ] man you know
like whatever i'm going through or like
maybe i'll be just be thinking about
something that day and i'll just i'll
sit down in front of the camera and i'll
go on like a 35 minute rant
you know what i mean like people people
love it dude i'm getting views i'm
getting you know what i mean like
i saw one video you did i watched it i
think it was earlier today that you were
you started out the video and you said
what the [ __ ] did you say you were
really angry though i think i'm gonna
rough oh no was i like i don't [ __ ]
owe anything yes
yeah yeah exactly yeah i don't owe
anybody anything
what was that video all about pay me my
[ __ ] money you know some little
[ __ ] punk on [ __ ] instagram uh
hitting me up and demanding that i
[ __ ]
tell him how to do fraud and all this
other [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] i'm
landing i was like no listen i was like
listen dude i just don't have the time i
was like i was like listen
he didn't want to pay me what i was
asking for you know what i mean i was
like listen dude i just don't have the
time to sit down and explain things that
he was like listen i work full-time i
tattoo full-time i'm doing youtube
and he came back he was like man [ __ ]
them tattoos pull your panties up
he's i was like damn all right
[ __ ] wow
yeah and then we're doing all right
we're doing all this and then he sends
me like a voice recording of himself
like you know what i mean like talking
[ __ ] to me
on instagram no well we were doing uh
like on a wicker on this like a separate
app or whatever
yeah i played it all on the [ __ ] i'm
on when i went off i played
[ __ ] i apparently didn't watch the
whole episode but oh yeah i played it
[ __ ] i
i read word for word like our whole
exchange and i played his [ __ ]
i put everything out there like [ __ ]
this little [ __ ] can you play it
right now
do you have it it's on my tablet oh [ __ ]
yeah it's on my tablet i didn't bring my
[ __ ] table and have it on my phone
but yeah no it's [ __ ]
check out the episode that's weird i've
come and got i've had people like that
like contact me just like just to like
talk [ __ ] [ __ ] who do you think you
are
[ __ ] you're gonna demand some
[ __ ] for me punk [ __ ] you don't know
what i do with my day you don't know how
[ __ ] structured my life is and
everything that i had to do to get to
where i
am and you're just gonna call me up and
just demand that i tell you some [ __ ]
yeah you can't let it get go [ __ ]
yourself that's why i that's that's why
i have this outlet
you know what i mean like because i feel
better like i'll get down and i'll just
go straight the [ __ ] off
and then i'll just be like as soon as i
shut that camera off dude it's just it
feels like weights have been lifted off
my chest and it's just like it doesn't
bother me anymore really
yeah it's kind of like therapy for you
and then yeah and then people like
my dude i have a [ __ ] fan base now
believe it or not like it's weird
oh yeah so you can't say that that i
have like a [ __ ] fan base now that
people that watch
everything i do and they comment on
every single thing so like when i put
one of these videos out and i'm like
feeling like [ __ ] or i'm feeling a
certain way
excuse me i'm feeling a certain way um
these people like are like oh y'all
don't worry about it [ __ ] bunch of
[ __ ] you know like
there's so much positivity like nobody
comes on my on my videos hating
or talking [ __ ] or anything like that
it's always i get no thumbs down
all thumbs up i'll do like 75 100
comments per video
3 400 views you know what i mean like
and it's like it's all positivity man
it's all positivity yeah people just
wanting to [ __ ] see me do more and
more and more
yeah yeah i just like i had no idea like
people were going to be this
interested in me and my life and like
because i i mean i don't really think
that i'm that interesting of a person
apparently i am yeah apparently
apparently people just like this to hear
me talk
you know what i mean and i me you know
whatever it is my personality maybe i
have a little bit of charisma or it's
the way i break things down and explain
things you know i
i i don't know what it is yeah